depuis plus de deux semaines le poste
frontière de medica est l'un des points
d'accès les plus fréquentés par les
réfugiés venus d'ukraine chaque jour des
centaines d'entre eux arrivent ici à
pied ou en voiture après un voyage
éprouvant
ces réfugiés sont en majorité des femmes
des enfants et des personnes âgées tous
sont exténués et démunis ils ont emporté
avec eux que le strict nécessaire et
pour certains leurs animaux de compagnie
lorsqu'il arrive c'est le soulagement
après l'horreur comme pour youla qui
vient de soumis une ville du nord de
l'ukraine où les bombes ont tué des
dizaines de civils
[Musique]
lorsque je suis arrivé ici
je me suis senti mieux mais dans ma
ville c'était atroce
nous avons été bombardés
il y avait beaucoup de morts
c'était vraiment horrible
à medica l'aide humanitaire est encore
sommaires et dépend des landes
solidarité venus de toute l'europe comme
celui de margherita ukrainienne de
crimée installé en suisse qui apportent
des vêtements chauds aux réfugiés
c'est super cette mobilisation spontanée
qui a eu lieu les gens sont organisés
que possible si on compare le temps
qu'ils ont fait et la quantité de
travail qu'ils ont à faire mais je pense
qu'il veut faire bien plus et qu'il
faudrait bien plus de gens impliqués
pour que les choses fonctionnent
correctement avec tout ce monde
au milieu de ce dénouement un moment de
grâce et quelques notes familière davide
martello un pianiste allemand qui
parcourt le monde avec son instrument
interprète imagine de john lennon pour
apporter un peu de réconfort à des
personnes en détresse comme il l'a fait
dans le passé sur la place taksim à
istanbul et devant le bataclan à paris
au lendemain des attentats
j'essaie d'accueillir les réfugiés
lorsqu'ils viennent d'une zone de guerre
ils ont peut-être entendu beaucoup
d'armes à feu de bon
lorsqu'ils arrivent ici ils peuvent
entendre ce genre de musique
ça leur donne comme un sentiment de
sécurité
alors que certains réfugiés passeront la
nuit dans le froid et dans les tentes
dressées à la hâte d'autres continuent
d'arriver jour et nuit dans medica
devenue terre d'accueil